I wanted something which would give
me a broader toolkit that I could
use at this stage of my career.
I also wanted to have access
to a global international cohort of
people who were doing lots
of interesting things
in their own careers.
A program which combine the two,
which I could do from
my dining table.
[MUSIC]
I realized there was something
different about this program.
The program pushed me outside my
comfort zone in
many of the assignments.
It forced me to look at myself
in different ways.
In my job, I have directly applied
course work.
Things like business model design,
designing organizations for
creativity and innovation in terms
of how I run meetings,
how I run my team.
Before I started LEAD,
I definitely thought of myself as
a finance professional in a bulge
bracket firm in New York City.
Now I think of myself as
an intrapreneur within my company
trying to build projects systems.
Managing people in different
countries, with different cultural
backgrounds, and yet trying to get
them to work towards the same goal.
Return on investment in LEAD is
a lot more than just the classes
you're attending.
It is about applying them and
then seeing how others are applying
them.
LEAD has really taught me that
you can be impactful
in anything you do.
It's an investment in myself as I
design the next phase of my own
life.
[MUSIC]